on it did you see what on it's doing
they get this going ticket like the
Charlie Charlie Chocolate Factory trying
Willy walk on the yeah that's what
they're doing up limits what do they
don't can win a trip if you scroll up
chins I can see you can win a trip you
want a bunch of prizes it's like Aubrey
Marquez Willy Wonka really
yeah alpha brain our brain golden ticket
sweets to sweepstakes so they got their
flagship nootropic which is the pride
and joy of the product line which Audrey
and Brendan Schaub and Joe Rogan
everybody I know takes and I guess what
happens is you get there you can
actually go to where yeah on it yeah
awesome so check it out so inside each
purchase of Alper alpha brain the 30 or
90 count bottles whenever you like
during the sweepstakes paired you'll
receive a golden ticket and if you're
selected you get a bunch of they're
giving out prizes and the grand prize is
an all-expense-paid trip to on it
headquarters in Austin Texas we've both
been there I was my plagues the utopia
for dudes got things that support
vitality they got things for performance
that shroom tech support which is sick
but maybe you're not into flying on it
so all you got to do if you're into
supplements they got you covered from
alpha brain to new mood they got earth
grown nutrients they got vitamins they
got krill or up they got it all on it
cough / Rider
10% off the whole damn sight on it calm
/ fighter so we got a lot of friends
that like to track their fitness yep
totally gets over October Bert Kreischer
Ari Shaffir Joe Rogan Tom Segura there
and this alright they're all wearing
this the whoop strap the rock in the
Whoopie and you can't rock with anybody
else I've been whoop with a I've been
with whoop for a little bit now yeah
yeah cuz that trust them yep I need
precise calculations not only am i work
out my output of course everyone can
track them yeah but what about my rest
yeah my boy Brian well my sleep my boy
Brian Kuja - owns jujitsu school well
showing me on his phone like everything
he tracks his sleep he can tell whether
he had 93% sleep it's just a will you do
this all time you can tell when you wake
up it'll track like you woke up 6
times in the night ten times in the
night now you know you got a problem but
it also tells you if you're gonna push
it maybe not today cuz you're at this
percentage recovery wise maybe do your
heart date this day I'm telling you when
I was a professional fighter I wish I
had this app which I had this device
we're talking about whoop we're talking
about well it's a cool looking strap to
it just looks like a black strap
five-day battery life live heart rate
monitoring improved Pro knit band
connects to your phone your iPhone your
Android can they track everything you
track you everything gets addictive when
you start looking at everything you're
doing you're like oh [ __ ] yeah I love it
I love it man whoop calm that's WH o o P
doc time use the code fighter at
checkout save $30 and optimized the way
you train again that's whoop dot-com
promo code is fighter at checkout hey
dude dude for 500 deep 500 deep balls
deep in the podcast I'm doing episode
it's funnies we even have more than that
out there I know this 500 and somebody
said to me luckily somebody said to me
recently they go um hey dude is it
getting old like you know you guys been
around I go
never better no maybe never better we've
got some of our no it's like you keep
chewing your food man it just keeps
growing it's just getting better and
growing it's great man five hundred to
five hundred anything no yeah I mean we
have Bobby here yeah you just keep going
yeah we're gonna do right we decided to
send out the bat-signal and Bobby Lee
answered yes for the 500th episode
dragon will be in at the Rey improv I
feel like this race is called Bobby the
man no I'm the man I'm the man drag okay
you're white no cuz I go and I and I
score him I score I said I'm on fire
okay dragon they call me the man dragon
now dragon man yeah that's right you
guys want to be turned to cinders you
come the Brea improv October 24 25 26
because man dragon dude ride the dragon
we're bring your fire retardant suits
they call me man Panther the man Panther
will be in Philadelphia next week
Thursday Friday Saturday man Panther aka
thick crust
aka big brown
kay fit kid Mick crust so I'll be in
Philly next week Thursday Friday
Saturday
then one night Pasadena Icehouse you got
some hilarious friends with me
that's on the 24th of October and then
just announced Dallas Salt Lake City
Kansas City that's all in November
Kansas City's December then in Atlantic
City
forget the casino some giant casino out
there first time in Jersey should be fun
last time I was in Jersey no I was doing
what knocking out Mirko Cro Cop is that
right you last time is right now I'm out
there slinging dick jokes Atlantic City
New Jersey December 14th get your
tickets Jersey teef at kake.com for
Dragonman and black panther get your get
your [ __ ] get the cat the Mike in
front of a sand would it's there the
sexiest man alive I need ears
you don't need ears dude we don't have
cans here just just let's not your kids
ID can't give me that you know you're
not getting here so now this is what
you're saying and what were you saying
in Korean tell me right now I was saying
that I go I just looked at ching chong
over here and i said hey that's so
offensive you're sorry I can say
anything like that toward him because we
have the connection yeah okay
okay I can call Brian cracker yeah why
you could do that it feels it feel bad
you know what you know what cracker
comes from though do you know what's
them slaves cracking the whip ing that
really on that black guy he'll called
the the white man crackers cuz they
would hit him it cracked I what I had to
do with the that the women would equip
would crack the food a cracker
not even offensive that we need better
words for miles yeah because I that's
why huh I don't know dude
yeah we and Facebook over here though
with this flat face Magoo right here
right please this guy in every Vietnam
movie yes the first one to die this guy
right here is the one in platoon Wow
that's one let me start off with my
opening monologue that I wrote on the
drive over here if you don't mind this
is why you're the 500 gasps yeah we
wonder if you don't mind me I open up
with a hundred episodes oh here we go
really so you know um I'm a connoisseur
sooner I just wrote this right now I
would love some like support some ethnic
support we're outnumbered Bryan we're
out my shoes agent as well yes three
chings versus two white when asian is
moving to your neighborhood the
neighborhood gets better it gets get
really real it gets cleaner and better
and more organized uh roars eggs it
disconnects my model out or what yeah I
please don't laugh okay so I enjoy great
works of art you know Sistine Chapel of
course beautiful I've heard the great
long I know what the Great Wall isn't a
piece of artwork but it is a a man-made
achievement yeah be able to keep that we
goes out yes Orion come I love going to
museums and I love seeing beautiful even
albums like a album like sergeant
Pepper's lion beetles yeah yeah and you
know over the years I haven't really
seen great art until this weekend and I
bought tickets to see a movie called
choker
and I saw an actor and that will be do
the best back acting work out now it
just has a low finish careful everyone
want I can you okay this is the screen
okay
this is the screen right here okay yeah
and when you can act only having this
much of your face in a screen probably
also just think of this hill in a split
second so this is this is only on the
screen for a split second Bobby to this
way you see right right this way
okay Bobby right way at the end of my
right and this end acting in this second
I stood up no in the theater now you
didn't say that no you know what I said
I'll be honest with you I stood up I
said loser look I turned it everyone in
the field I don't know Bobby
in fact I told you this earlier when he
was in the bathroom right my
girlfriend's knees from the Philippines
right was in the theater okay
when you we heard your voice yeah on
kalila goes hey did the knees Bobby no
that's just friend you know what I said
the knees super shitty this is a big
opportunity for you big it's a big movie
you're both beat my mom takes me she I
went she doesn't wanna see the jokesters
I'm excited you know she loves yeah yeah
I'm excited to see bride like no doubt
mom three hours later she goes oh I
didn't see Bryan are you even on the
call sheets when you're that like does
it go to a thousand I got a call he was
outlet for a while there I got a call
and before that took four days bother
for the other for why and and Todd was
like hey just come out and do this
little part and I do anything he tells
me because I love him and but but you do
get to a point in your life where you
like that's that not a that's us and I
was treated like such an extra I was
walking around
and I'm going to I'm like I'm like where
is the where's the food or I was like
I'm used to being in a craft using my
ass a little bit yeah yeah okay and the
guy goes like this
wrong way you we got no shirt yeah Hika
piece your pants and [ __ ] shoes and I'm
like I'm just like okay New York and an
old textile a rug making Factory okay
and on top of that what game Phoenix
wouldn't look in my direction
oh yeah I'm not hello goodbye wouldn't
look in my direction cuz you know he
said he's a piece of the doctor yeah
yeah and I was just saying I get here
yeah yeah and then I was like thank you
for coming in and doing this small part
yeah the best I was like anything for
you which is check what can I say -
anything forms I don't care yeah I you
know I did a little Davey spades little
Davey Spade you know a little Davey
spared yeah I know David's I did a
little Davey spades movie or in the
summer which was called misses something
I forgot but um he goes it's one line
and I go oh where's that Hawaii oh and I
go oh that's me tough yeah and he goes
you're doing it right and then he just
cut you such a nice guy so I just said
you guys an item's gonna be their rights
Handler and I show up and it was the
worst acting it was so hard yeah I had
one line that's welcomed like open
business for it yeah yeah and you're in
the background yeah this is gonna be the
case of the Joker I hear this yeah I
knew it was gonna be I was like well
it's okay it's worth it I did a movie in
Thailand and the ad came up to me three
days in and said you're still here and I
had work in three days so I've been
there more dealer no one knows what
you're doing there you're in a stable
the thousand other one of these
changings right yeah and you're all it
sucks no I won't do it
don't
I'll do it as if it's Todd because I
love him he's a genius yeah of course he
be remember the time I went to that
movie premiere and we thought you were
gonna be in it and we both got dressed
though we're sitting the theater yeah I
love that one short say I was here now
that was in the Kevin Hart movie it was
not about last night yeah it was bad was
about last night Marius yeah well you
know you're not you're not just you
don't matter I know they can replace you
and hey here's or not thinking I grow up
grello oh this was when he was this was
I'll take exactly this was 15 16 years
ago and Frank Frank quit and I wits each
other our auditions banging out you know
TV here and there Frank and soap operas
sank was do it Frank would do like a
series wouldn't go then he wouldn't work
for a long time it's like anything else
so um we're watching The Godfather or
something I said to him I go I remember
I said how cool would be to be in a big
movie imagine being in a big movie like
that just like just acting and getting a
real part and he goes I did I got one
did and I go you didn't English I mean I
just booked a movie with Tom Cruise and
Steven Spielberg and I was like 14 he
goes it's called Minority Report I love
that well I go what and he was like dude
I'm calm I'm going I'm gonna be gone for
two months and you back then you have to
understand that's the biggest thing on
that so yeah that's like you made it
like here we go it here we go yeah yeah
here we [ __ ] go cuz now you're no
longer TV guy cuz TV and film two
different businesses
yes Russian you're done yeah yeah your
insurance exactly but even back in the
80s when somebody said I got booked as a
series regular on a sitcom usually he
would go that you're sad you reaction
would be okay no yeah my god will you be
so impressed by cuz it would be a
life-changing event from making no money
to being able to buy a house yeah it's
insane but now what would there's
nothing really the equivalent of nothing
right not there's nothing so so so so
Frank so Frank is right
yeah what this podcast yeah doing
something like a podcast if you have a
large podcast yeah it happened for you
it happen for you yeah but it takes I
don't know why I say
twice happen for you for you but there's
a thing when you record this it's not
like when we start the podcast
especially your group of friends yeah
who are actors and be [ __ ] in
Hollywood when you start the podcasts
not like oh you made knows everybody
commit everybody was making fun of me
for starting upon yes I was made fun of
I know you were I was literally like
they were like what analysis what do you
do with this [ __ ] podcasting now so
so Frank so Frank back to Frank so he's
gone for like two months it's the
biggest coup in the world I'd go to the
premiere with my girl and I'm like I'm
gonna see my boy Tom Cruise movie this
is usually he was acting with him yeah
it seems everything I was like what he
like asked some questions a you don't
know this when you're when you're in a
movie you don't know this that this
happens to you if you're if you're
supporting actors your agent not no he
doesn't so he comes you ahead so how but
he sees the final cut you don't know
this so he gets the movie I get to the
movie and I'm like where's Frank listen
right and you see him lean over a
banister hit him all I really not you
see him lean over abanazar in the mall
he's wearing a cop helmet and he turns
like this and goes that's all he did
there's no I he's right no okay all
right Frank no I was a few one if I were
worse things if Brody had that happen to
him worst day one oh I had a worse thing
happen to me unfortunately all right so
I get a call the Billboard Awards is
doing a thing with you know who's that
guy from the King I know I'm out his
name is uh he's one of the Kings of
Comedy uh the heath name or B know
anyone with Harvey does he well who you
going to him yeah so did he's very
talented by the way super talented a big
fan I like I like Li I just [ __ ] though
I've always liked that guy is great
really nice yeah so they go I go what do
they want me to do they want you to
dress up as kim jeong-hoon and sit in
the audience and do what and they're
like we're gonna really bring a special
effects team and you were gonna make you
look just like him I go cool but what do
I do
DL will point you out
the audience and then we wrote this deal
where you guys need to riff back and
forth right
and so I show up at rehearsal he's not
there right so I go but he's not here
and they go we know but he will be he
knows yeah but he did it with everyone
else and I've been here the whole time
he didn't do with me
they get he had to do something he's
fine so I spent like six hours and
prosthetic makeup right my manager is
God I don't know how but you got a seed
directly behind me why is it the bath
and this is like before this should they
come listen it works the best if you do
you stay in character from beginning to
end
I go okay they go even if people talk to
you you just say you're conjunct on all
right so I'm sitting there on full
makeup already so depressing but also I
could feel I could feel the sweat
building up inside the cheek prosthetics
so uncomfortable right so it's building
up like what every time we're doing here
and just so you guys know they glue it
on there by the glue it I don't you a
surgical glue all right and then put
this plastic on your face it's it's the
worst I think they're really breathable
yeah and they don't know you so you're
the first one they be added on I neither
the last when they take it off right so
I'm sitting there and then deal you I
know exactly what he does for us to get
into this thing and he's going into the
thing and I'm sitting there like this
going okay okay and he doesn't do it
[Laughter]
like I'm flat bobbing like as he keeps
talking he's not doing it and I'm
sitting like this and then he goes to a
commercial break right I'm serious I
love waving like this and I'm going oh I
think you forgot right right and then
all of a sudden like [ __ ] manager
who I'm still with [ __ ] her she's like
this she's whispering that for three
hours
all right so I'm sitting there the whole
time like this now if they had a camera
on me from before and after I wish they
had that because before it was like this
but then it was like three hours of you
see like just looking at people right
and then my gosh it's in Vegas juice I'm
not even in LA right I remember like
getting the [ __ ] off and like the
producers going with we don't know what
happened
you know me and it goes there's nothing
there nothing like I'm not on in like no
you didn't even have a camera on you
really there's like 800 bucks you got
400 bucks
I mean there's so many of those like
show business to see like nightmarish
things that happen in your career but
you you don't quit right and then
eventually you get things that yeah
people do see Jamie Foxx there's no
there's no record of that there's no pet
I'd love to see you yeah Jamie Foxx I
think it was him talking about how or I
heard this I don't know if it he did a
stand-up thing at for Robert De Niro's
birthday recently at a dinner it was
like a dinner now it was a while back
and he was supposed to comment I think
it was him and it he just ate all the
dicks
he starts roasting De Niro do knows like
this yeah I don't do it I don't do I
want to corporate gigs and oh yeah I
will do it I won't ruminant you kid
though he's only the video really oh
dude look at this I was like oh hell no
see hope your montedio goes aid in
Christmas party let's do it at some
billionaires house
no I every single day since that
happened I think about that show every
single day you drive down the street how
long do we don't think about it Oh cuz
you cringe how long ago is it last
Christmas
what yeah I haven't really talked to him
since then the video it's what happened
he was a billionaires house yeah
you know that little almost something
racist came out something racist came
out all the SafeZone I want to correct
no this is not the don't you're in
serious not the safe zone
this is mrs. not I lost all my jobs if
it was I know so he hangs out with this
very talented young man but in a of re
you know him I know his opener yes yes
did you do he's Jewish she is right it
has nothing to do with anything story
okay fYI she even said it alright so he
ends up with a very talented young man
and this kid you know he's one of those
guys he hangs out the store for years
and how you know you're in conversation
with like you know with the comic that
you've been asked friends with for 20
years yeah and there's a guy this kind
of like just standing there around he's
not with anybody he's caught it in the
conversation but you don't [ __ ] know
and he's just kind of standing there
doing this yeah I mean and then all of a
sudden you you have to include them
right your name is Ari right don't you
think and then they added and they're
your friend all of us on it just because
you have to work in this environment
right right this [ __ ] guy goes up
before me and destroys this guy re right
I'm that so I'm like yeah this guy's
killer I'm gonna destroy this [ __ ]
thing I bomb so bad that I see Theo
go like this I've met and it's she's so
far away and he does this he looks at
the stage at the ago that is like anyone
shakes their head from a mile away and I
just saw his every figures it no I get
out it's not work it was the three of
you yeah it did not work how did do do
he killed anyway well because you need
anyone that didn't do well oh no do I
know Ari who ease you don't worry all
right so the chemistry what's his last
name we got to figure it I don't know
yeah it's some Josh affair no we're not
that honest right that's right ma zouri
madness yeah yeah he's a beast but do
you know you you go through all these
nightmare
in your in your I have I have like 50
nightmares that I have in rotation in my
brain oh it's there right and it's
constantly in this playlist yeah man you
know it torture myself well we all stand
but you know it's like sometimes you
just have cringe-worthy moments was it
just cringe worthy hours I did if I did
stand up in London I like ten I did the
best part about there's like London can
just get off like you got a power
through it you know that nobody laughed
and oh my god no one because it not only
could they not hear me i also was trying
stuff I hadn't done I was just bad and
and then some woman goes she she looked
at me she goes don't take this the wrong
way but you're very American I said I
was just so big and loud and I was like
oh okay and then I had sex with a guy
never forgot it had sex with a girl who
was who worked in the stables there and
she had an amazing body but I've never
seen a face like this it could stop a
clock she had the kind of teeth
the joke is she had the kind of teeth
her teeth were so bad that if I threw an
apple at her face it would stick like
that was good
the job sorry I'm sorry I mean she had a
great body out of course I had a great
time with her all right yes there was
that I bombed so bad I bomb but bombed
like oh and then I did a corporate gig
first time I made a lot of money for a
corporate gig yeah my buddy Jimmy Burke
sent me up again in up at a pool at 4:00
in the afternoon outside on a makeshift
stage I started trying to do jokes and
I'm not kidding if five minutes in
because it was just so bad
the guy Lugo's Bry right right finally
he's no that's not good he goes rot
right poolside Bry wrap it up right now
where were we
hey do you remember is it might have
been staying triply sure I forget but it
was at at like a hotel but it was like
in
at a club and it was outside but they're
like sir serving hors d'oeuvres no one's
really paying attention and all the cops
going up there everyone's eating [ __ ]
yeah everyone's eating [ __ ] then you
went up and crust you remember that I
was like six or seven years ago remember
that I can't remember it was somewhere
off Sunset at a whole I'm pretty sure
it's Sam's show yeah well it might have
been but there's also like a bunch of
weird girls there remember that were
handing out like food and stuff yeah I
think that was my health
yes that was in a [ __ ] yes that was
in a hotel that was uh that when people
were died they were eating oh my god is
all yeah but when I see that I get mad
I'm gonna do well after that when I see
guy one soldier falling after another if
I'm following that up rowdy you can I'm
gonna do well because okay you guys get
mad and you're like all right [ __ ]
look at you now though yeah I mean you
get mad and then like you you're
resentment that's another thing that I
had to change about my act as a
performer is if that was bombing I think
you've even said things to me because i
used to memorize the last shot even I
would used to do well and think I was
not doing you always crushed it you've
always crushed you're one of the
funniest people ever yeah but here's the
prize I can't believe you if you were to
get out you're like drives me nuts if
you would if you were to get offstage
and every time with oh I crush then I
can be Bobby Lee you know yeah the
people I get offstage your timing all I
crush thing but you don't write much
right you're not a big writer I love
that hello it is all right now no
because I think you know your part
you're part of what you're doing what
Rogan and all those guys do what I love
it
you're one of the bad you're a part of
that whole we want more songs your ear
bud Zeppelin one more time secular it
made one song free bird pretty great
song great song I'll just do it every
day I know it's so funny it's never
gotten tired of watching have it's funny
that you say that you make me laugh
every time I watch I said well yeah like
that over I want more songs yes over
Iying
I'm not dying number one I know so
number two is this year at my age yeah
is the most money the most everything
I've ever done is this year good it gets
better and better
and there are people bullies like you
right these are [ __ ] comedy balloons
I hear you I'll just don't do it you
right Joe Rogan yeah
mark is a little bit like that Marc
Maron a little bit okay to me oh is it
yeah you you're definitely at me again I
know and when I did we throw tonight
when I used to see you back in the day I
used to feel joy why now it's kind of
dread no no a little bit when I see you
like what did I run into the other day
because I'm a ghost or cuz I'm a boy
yeah I get scared like you're gonna pull
me into something and you and Rogan and
I I don't what your round that's why I'm
here
that is what don't stat don't get
nervous friend cuz it when I went up
when I shoot up school no you're off
you're not on the list
no yes I handle Oh first guy we only got
only good bro I would shoot you but I'm
your 300 times in just your stupid
[ __ ] face that you guys just saw Joe
no cuz my career that's all you're here
your career your careers a mate dude
your career is the reason why I'm here
you just made fun of my [ __ ]
performance I know because I'm kidding
to be a part of like you know you're
kind of a bully too you [ __ ] didn't
return my he didn't return my texts and
then you returned mine yeah let me tell
you so bright we need a special guest
for the 500th episode right and so we're
trying to do it I text him twice nothing
and I went Bobby Lee be perfect guest
for this big episode yeah it does a seem
special though really like streamers or
there's no expert legs like a little
thing well we have something well we'll
see the the show's not open wrap now I'm
gonna so I put yo job you around this
coming Wednesday we're doing the 500th
episode fighting the kid once you be a
guest please and he put I'm in I don't
respond to Brian because he's an old see
you Wednesday yeah
we have to bleep out in stores now now
hold on you know it's together wish you
had I never did that oh my god you got
caught now you're embarrassed I never
did that man you're wrong bro that
wasn't my tax right that wasn't you know
that was
actually ending to be Bobby Lee you're a
bully dude you're the comedy bully oh
you think I am that's impossible
you're a how could I bully anybody I'm
not an alpha male well I like the fifty
shades of red though I have no muscles
on my body you've seen my body yeah
what Oh what do you mean I know what you
know I know you know what you know
what's so funny
wow this is great dude I'm glad we're
here ching chong right I'm so glad we're
here we can really just kind of get it
out oh we get it all out there yeah
that's good because I honestly feel and
I'm not leaving this is not even a bit I
feel whew tension with you guys no yeah
a little bit yeah no you give them my
girlfriend [ __ ] guys Wow
dude well hate to say this everyone
gives you a girlfriend [ __ ] guys hey
come on take it easy stop giving him
you're giving him serious eyes now
you're getting an accusation eyes my
body just do a hard restart I got you a
little Harley Bobby I'm cursed you don't
want a guy just know I felt that and I
felt but here's the thing though that's
I get mad that you drive a Ferrari and
people look at it yeah you know that
sign-up drive Ferrari also girls girls
want amazing job that's here smart girls
when I'm eight was shoving their
instinct their instinct lot signs I see
giant the giant yeah yeah a dress like
candy yeah yeah he's shiny and he's cute
I want that section
yeah Shaba has Lester all right but shop
it has an interesting thing you have be
cool there honestly does does he have a
thing in this car a blue thing do you
park anywhere Oh does he have one of
those it's called the handicapped I
don't want to say that because I got one
of those uh nope okay
but I just parked wait I know what
you're saying I know what you're [ __ ]
saying oh yeah this is so [ __ ] me
what do I say
you say you're suggesting that he has he
has a learning problem that he looks
like he's a little bit mentally
challenged
really that's what you [ __ ] cuz you
looked at them and you go your your face
or something and why is your voice
getting hot now that's where you're
going with this where were you going
with it what yeah what did you mean by a
guy missing a little bit of uh dude I'll
tell you why can I tell you why you
can't I never said this no you can't oh
I know what it is he look like George
from mysen man yes hello Lenny look
honey I killed any white dude that size
with that big of a head children what
you say when you say a Brenda and he
turns around and his eyes do this a
little bit and you're like oh there's
something wrong like I love things yeah
my gosh I'd like your baby right now
dude that's not nice let's go let's call
up your girl see what she's me go whew
let's hear you talk like this let's call
up your girl what she thinks
let's go up you're [ __ ] my girl no
sob gate [ __ ] dude
sorry dude you know but you're not
touching you anymore man why you don't
have tension with me you should be more
worried about Brian around your girl
than me I'm not really I'm not really
like you
I look at you like a look at Rogan now
and I look at bill burr maybe why what
do you mean just like you know I'm
standoffish a little bit a little like a
little distance okay that's not true
trust my because I know that [ __ ]
yeah your success that's such [ __ ]
I've never thought that in my life yeah
I don't start off your own show No so
what I don't feel like I said that I saw
the numbers yesterday yeah good oh nine
one point oh yeah we do well yeah the
Goldberg are splitting up you know we
might the show I was on you opened with
a to 7:00 a.m. then what happened in the
you know rosanne scald that lady from
Obama was it Planet of the Apes yeah
like that which was wrong and then she
got fired off of the Roseanne in the
Conners dip because we followed them and
then now we were canceled that ABC yeah
thanks for saying and you're so funny
because of the two years I was on and
you never even said anything
I didn't I don't watch TV I don't know I
don't watch my own show Bobby how did
you find out is canceled above me did
you know it was happening
yeah I live on planet earth I have all
the devices so you knew is headed there
yeah I saw a chance or something
they text you there's a look good buddy
well Brian it no use them in the joke
school tonight 8:30 on ABC what oh man
that is dirty what well you guys she'll
Warner Brothers where you got [ __ ] how
Sony that's not a lie yeah yeah so close
to me that shows good and that you're
very funny in it and congratulations
well thank you and you'd be a great show
thanks for having mom by the way we'll
do it thanks for having I swear to god
I'll recommend you
I don't wanna do it do you want to keep
doing TV Bobby yeah I just was a new
Magnum right now I'm doing a reoccurring
on that working on the FBI is there
another man but it's the way I know I
know you know what like when when dumb
people blurt out and they do that yeah
I'm talking to change on record oh he
just did there you don't have to shame
him but could we all know where he is
mentally we all know where he is
she's not real no he's not landing hobby
I thought I just such a taste I thought
they canceled magnum p.i okay I thought
I can't get they canceled it in the
seventies when it was a show and now
there's a new one no idea who's Magnum
who's Magnum
who's the new Magnum journalist oh you
don't know Jay let me say Pig bring him
up he works a lot and he's a nice guy
do you worth a lot are you what are you
playing on the show Kim Jeong Jin that
stuff okay so I brought up I'm gonna
enjoy it that's a handsome son in there
he didn't have a mustache though oh he's
from
good-looking dude oh he's uh he's in
suicide suicide squad he's the flame guy
not only that he was in five minute
lights you know a bunch of [ __ ]
now he's now he's the key is the place
Tom Selleck keep playing he's Magnum [ __ ]
shot I'm gonna say this is that when I
go to Hawaii and I shoot that show
you're you have to shoot for two weeks
by the way cuz it's like you know in
Hawaii in 11 days what in Hawaii
how is Hawaii yeah you know you're not a
beach guy I love it
yes I've been there for
so I've been there doing the show and I
love him so much I love the cast so much
that that's why I go over there he's a
great guy he's he's like you know what
it is is that because he's friends with
Ike Barinholtz - you know Ike yeah and
he's just it doesn't seem like he's
knows that he is the number one in the
call chain he acts like he is just a
career person - oh do well I think it
doesn't go well in Europe I don't think
it does well in the States but like
David doesn't matter they're in it see
and I have a fake mustache in the show
you know but anyway I've been doing that
it's been fun you know I'm in so you
know splitting up together got cancelled
I doing that Tiger was sowing my dad
died you know so funny because out of
every oh yeah that's why I'm here back
up turn that off
oh yeah he's going hard huh 500 I'm
under I gotta go hard so we're this is
about honesty it's about honor and being
real fleshing out some issues yeah you
stopped buying this girl you stopped
thinking I'm so successful and amazing
and be like I don't think that on sale I
don't think that I don't think no you
came out cuz you bolt you know you shove
you around the hallway a little bit
sometime a lot okay you get really
physical and then you'll come up and
you'll grab the neck yeah you'll do muy
Thai like lunges yeah my throat or my
chest region I like me when I'm talking
to like agents or something important it
makes me look foolish but his friends
were in a shirt that says fighters clubs
let's just acknowledge that hey I came
to the I knew it was gonna bother you I
showed up with my when my my I got a
bunch of stuff from eight-man strong
yeah cuz CB Dollaway
that's his company yeah it says
eight-man strong and I knew and I walked
in with a teacup sweatshirt says
eight-man strong yeah roasted but he
would be like he was like that bothers
me don't walk around like that cuz and
you actually physically grabbed me I did
anyway boys me the way you doing my dad
died oh okay didn't I send you a nice
text and it's funny because I you know I
go into the dad dying and then you guys
go into this little side like you know
like you know Seinfeld kind of like
dialogue he's sorry sorry dude [ __ ]
crazy talk I'm sorry man but I want to
say is
out of all my friend he said when I
posted that my dad died Chris D'Elia was
the very first person out of anyone to
get a hold of me it said from my
girlfriend so I wanted you true or false
it is true but can I say this
yeah it wasn't enough well dude I don't
know if to call somebody when that
happens I don't know how grief you
should have went over this house am I
not mmm ching-chong yes
can we let's get real let's get Korean
is that enough to me yeah you me though
you should I'm over the house I like
moist cakes man well we love moist case
with a little fruit inside I didn't know
we like to see the peach oh right
I I like that I heard it was you know
what and you know what that taught me
what it showed me that we're not really
that close it's fine it's nice close
with you close with you you can use your
dad die nothing I had no idea
you had no idea Jim I had no idea
[Applause]
so same I had no idea no told me wait
wait Bobby show Randall's show Brennan
for real yeah so Bobby's in his car I
said dude I'm sorry about your dad how'd
you how'd you find out I heard it from
somebody and I saw I sent him house on
the road I didn't know so I've talked
about this a couple times now probably
10 times Bobby's car and he goes this is
un season really disturbing and he
showed me one of the most beautiful
pictures I'm not kidding I've ever seen
in my life
one of the most powerful pictures I've
ever seen in my life this is the moment
his father died okay hold on let me just
set it up okay his mother who's been
with him for how long for how long Bobby
what my mother's been there for with her
for 52 years 52 years now take a look at
this I'm ready for this picture it's
it's so powerful are you a man it's so
powerful so this which one do you want
the group photo or the one that's room I
want the one
yeah your brother your Martin this is
the moment my mind my dad died ready I
want to show it on though okay yeah
that's why it's personal it's beautiful
it's one of the most powerful pictures
I've ever seen oh wow
dang look at that is that that's your
brother in the back it's so incredible
though cuz she's looking down at him and
this is somebody she's been with for 52
[ __ ] yeah yeah thanks for sad for
sure it's sad you know what the worst
was it cuz u cos oh so I was at that dog
house the chili dog plays over there
yeah and I was eating chili dogs yeah I
should not because I'm gonna get
diabetes yeah high blood pressure yeah
my body is all [ __ ] up you know I
might not make it but um and I was about
to chew into the first hotdog you know
and then my mom called and she said you
would the combo you have to come now in
Phoenix in Phoenix so a my brother I
call my brother and and I get tickets
and we to fly over there and so when we
walked in the hospice my dad was
completely like conscious and he knew
when I walked in you could tell his face
changed yeah you know you cried a little
bit and he became happy cuz he knew I
was there and my brother and I was
aren't there and then the lady comes in
and she goes okay actually he doesn't
know that and so when we saw my dad we
thought oh he's not sick he's like
Norman is there yeah but then the
hospice they go we have to stop feeling
it feeding him because his chest and a
stomach is in fact it's so so we can't
feed him anymore and the one that once
they said that my brother freaked the
[ __ ] out yes yeah he said what do you
mean yeah bad yeah in the room because
what do you mean opposed at best it's
just you know how is it gonna leave even
feel right doing that alright and so
that now and my mom's hysterical so now
I'm there I'm the oldest I'm the one
that makes most of the money right all
right Bobby why are you looking for Mike
because I know that about that right now
but I had to just show sure everyone's
young Carina in the room so there
says he knows he gets you don't he
doesn't get all your number one provides
for the vision you don't get it you
doofus piece of [ __ ] huh you know what
also was a shirt I was at oh yeah I was
in Portland doing a show and the front
row four dudes with the pocket shirt
yeah right a fighter like I said I you
screamed at everyone like there's a
demon where yeah I worse I like your
clothes
Thanks was I even saying your brother
gets pissed
oh yes oh my god yes it might and then
so now I'm the Korean guy I have to be
on the oldest so I have to stay keep it
together but the next seven days
yeah was the worst 70 it's like you go
there I was a Monday and then Thursday
was where I was like to my brother I was
like I can't even come I can't even go
there because it was sad dude it's 3:00
in the morning my brother's he goes I'm
gonna stay there all night every night
to the hospitals my brother 4:00 in the
morning my brother's showing me photos
of my dad staring at the ceiling
yeah we've been doing this like like
he's hallucinating why got 11 I'm not
you're smiling he laughs at these kinds
of stories guys I don't how to react
yeah I'm laughing at the way we were to
Santa Monica from [ __ ] Studio City
for your 500 [ __ ] laughs my god I
know you're right no way you did go like
this Bobby wait no Bobby like this way
you went like this you didn't go like
that again okay and I swear to God if
you smile even Bret empty I'm [ __ ]
leaving okay all right hey [ __ ] Lee
you [ __ ] don't smile got you
smiling just this is about this is
really serious story
hmm I got it tell story again tilt chin
to chin time smart
nobody [ __ ] my will no one [ __ ]
love this is serious for on Tuesday my
Bozak yeah it like uh well it's already
not working we're now but you can't say
though all right baby let's tell you say
we got I bet I beg I beg you please
oh no you're gonna make you please I beg
you please okay alright I love my dad so
much
yeah you're the star dessert but don't
so uh he goes did I'm stay right all
right but don't send me those photos no
more Ryan say ah right right to the
first one three in the morning maybe
Wednesday night right is like this
dude we're not laughing [ __ ] you know
laughing man but also Bobby don't make
those faces I know I'm telling you it is
the way it is alright so I'm just gonna
do it like this for my brother
no you can't point I me Brian I wasn't
laughing about it just take your thing
off your hand you can do it
you listen be real oh you're right be
real and I'm your friend right no person
and I'm saying something else we're
sorry I have been your father
I really heard is devastating and let's
start okay so anyway my brother's be
like my brother you're laughing now
dude you're laughing why are you
laughing you're having them you're
having it you know what this is part of
the grieving this is part of the
grieving process
I'm glad we're here for it you know this
is actually part of the grieving process
late listen Jule acquiesce anyway my
brother goes on yeah dude I'm gonna stay
helmet
all right don't send me the photos then
like so the first one was like um like
there's just regular right but then like
but then they at 4:00 in the morning
it's like that right and then by like
6:00 in the morning like these are the
photo what what do you doing yeah what
are you doing cover that's it you know
what you did a great job you did okay
that's the end of the story that's it
thank you now that's powerful when my
dad's dad died when my father dies dad I
was with him and the doctor said it's
catastrophic it doesn't look like it's
gonna go along and my father one like
this this is how he felt about his dad
he goes I'm standing right next time he
goes like this
don't came to history face it's so bad
he goes don't prolong life oh wow how
was I who you you really he goes don't
prolong life any time mixed and I said
I'm sorry about your dad and he goes
okay
a84 does well with no he didn't like his
dad but he didn't like him didn't like
his dad
you suck with emotions to them yeah I
got it from my parents
yeah we keep it we keep it bottled up
yeah you know it's like older people
from different generations I think they
react to grieve differently however
sense right it's just that yeah yeah
well cuz they probably still went
through the wars and they're like wow
he's like now it comes out that's what
was behind him that was behind his face
the whole time about he doesn't even
deserve one career to come here and you
tell stories all right you can put your
shirt I have a little bit of meat head
you can have a little my buddies I mean
you're blending in with the couch so
hard it's red homewrecker branding so
hard with the couch but if you can pull
your shirt down a tiny bit
you know I mean that's what I want to
get out of here no I'm feeling bad vibes
right yeah
Bobby alright we love here I love you
too why don't why don't you ever have me
on Tiger belly you have you not done it
one so long - yeah yeah yeah and I wanna
be the first I'm oh my [ __ ] special
oh yeah
you did it you don't want me on your
Papa don't know what half over there was
we disappeared schedule complex that's
true that's true when do you do it it's
a good time Monday nights I do it every
Monday night and I have a new house and
we moved from the house I was in yeah uh
yeah I have a new place and I built I'm
building up podcasts to do much like
this much little different you would you
do you want to be more of you want to
act only and not to stand up or do you
want to do that what is stupid what what
do we doing I want I don't have a
special I should get out of stand-up
know I just feel like I'm on say [ __ ]
relation I listen you said to me I want
to I wait just wasn't Portland I don't
do press sellout every fell yeah Irvine
sellout every show Jesus right Brea
sellout every show Jesus
oh you know Denver Chicago right why do
I need to do more than that K I'm not
saying right and I remember years ago
you did something and I really want to
thank you what is it I don't think that
you meant to what you met did but I want
to thank you years ago when Ken Jong was
blowing the [ __ ] up you sat next to me
because I was gloomy that couldn't get
any work and you looked at me and you
put your arms around me and you said to
me are you type why don't you try acting
class thank you
did you track did that make you more
angry and so then you I hated you for
years yeah because I needed counsel and
like you know I tried to fix you try to
fix headcounts like I wanted to be
nurtured by you yeah but you just kind
of was like you know your fault
yeah yeah right you're not making it cuz
you're not good your talent is basically
what you just know I said that in my
head
you've heard a lot of stuff that I
haven't said I don't know well you know
my realer you're earning I like really
deciding that's that he's got given eyes
to your girl you've decided as a joke do
you know that I fully these are all
jokes these are fake money relationship
right angles they take or kneecaps with
but at the end of the day I finish what
I'm willing to say you [ __ ]
sorry but hey hit you hit you struck
both of us we've never been hit on our
podcast and you physically accosted I've
never been treated so poorly what
thought uh podcast I'll be honest I felt
like this all of the time all right
the picture I want to explain the thing
is is that the reason why I'm here this
is the my footages but that's not what I
was gonna say this is the first podcast
I've done since my dad passed Wow you
know so this is um and the reason I
would only go to a place where I feel at
home say if you do that and safe and
that's why when you ask me to do this
I said 100% I'd like to come home but
when it came here it was a rape party oh
my oh my see a party party on my soul no
don't say rape yeah and it's like knife
it was spiritually raped here no and
that's not what I wanted to know so I
lied I've done like nine other projects
my dad passed you're not special I feel
like we got raped now you do we were
read that you exactly okay so you move
on with the pro Matt Matt Lauer move on
with your program whatever you have next
your videos yeah did you did you do you
play a lot of video games you know you
can cut this part you cut this the
audience basalt yeah it's not alive I
don't want this error this next part and
I really understand being real I think
my dick smells weird all right so can
you smell the tip of my dick and there's
a gay but all right no I'll go a
distance with just to see where's Mel
anything from a distance do it Brian
come on get in there
you get my man Bobby what the [ __ ] dude
that was it
trick thing you just want me to get
close to your dong that's that's it oh
that's real I like that why do you like
that trick you like it yeah yeah you
gotta be willing to do yeah yeah yeah
weird
you know I've done that a thousand times
you hear the first person that said oh
I'll do it yeah but you know I was gone
and he was dead serious I was looking at
the tip of it to see if there was any
yellow discharge and I was said I
agraria oh you're going to drip oh sorry
yeah doc you try and be a good friend
but you pulled it out like a dead baby
bird and you squeezed it at me so I just
saw balls and the head of your dog all
right hey you know how we're talking
about mark Normand doing that press in
the morning in pour is it Portland area
where you've seen bobbies no yes you
kissed a girl
what guys grab the ribs press okay we
can I stop missed it I know we were
about to say yeah could you already said
it
yeah yeah language wise I don't listen
so thank you for laughing I'm sorry but
what we say okay let's get back now cuz
you on TV you behaved crazy
yeah what do you mean she'd get sport
though she'd be smart who oh yeah yeah
so what you're saying is those those
morning ones just cute I eat so early in
the morning yeah I never know what to do
in those morning ones who does so I'll
just chase them around even dude like
I'll kiss them like on their face yeah
like a newscaster like he'll be talking
well you know we've got a comedian I'll
just immediately kiss him on the cheek
that's them and then like my agent or
some old Kong go yeah I mean you can't
do that no more that's not the nineties
you can't like touch people that's so
silly yeah and I go it's silly your
let's what do you do we have a Matt
Lauer in there in the press I didn't we
didn't pick that one did you what are
you didn't pick that one what do you
think of that that Laur likes that booty
so so so he had sex with this gal they
were really drunk she did six shots of
vodka she came up to his
- I'm a slice though when she came in
because he took her credentials and then
he invited her was like once you come
they had a whole relationship I think it
was out I think he's in trouble she's
saying she she got raped she did that
anal sex she was so drunk she passed out
but but he left the room and then she
[ __ ] him a bunch of times after their
relationship after and then now she's
saying that one time I had sex was rape
because I didn't give my verbal consent
and it's like Abby you [ __ ] him after
that
yes like she said she had to because of
her career she worked out for totally
different thing it's like dude what's up
with you well I just think that [ __ ] up
[ __ ] with women have really been raped
man I'm sorry I just I don't know I
don't know how what am I supposed to do
about that yeah you're I'm saying so you
agree that after you guys had anal sex
and then you woke up and you were like
oh [ __ ] I had anal sex and then you then
you come back and have sex with him over
and over again a bunch of times you go
to his apartment a bunch of times you
guys carry on a relationship then it
doesn't end well and a minute that you
file the complaint embassy fire that guy
in 24 hours he was gone
yeah okay so but if he raped you then
look at this which one I mean do you
know what I'm saying it's like what the
[ __ ] are we doing here yeah well if you
can come back and say is that wonderful
in the sense that I was too drunk to
consent yeah but you were consenting you
enough after that well so you're a grown
adult you did six shots of vodka is he
supposed to read your mind you guys are
both drunk again from he was drinking
right well don't leave the problem with
that yeah that's that's a little gray
there but they had sex a bunch of times
after that's what's so weird to me
I'm sorry Tori that this is the
territory that I don't like treading on
well the problems nobody talked about
it's like the world we live in and we
just have to be very very very very
careful guys what do you think why I'm
telling the truth
I'm not careful about this I'm telling
I'm saying this is confusing to me
and I think it's also damaging to to
women's claim I think it's
fusing for Matt Lauer library what we
hooked up a [ __ ] thousand times after
that what that's that's a really
dangerous precedent to me you're talking
about when you accuse somebody of rape
that's the end of their life right we
know that right it's the end of their
[ __ ] life it's basically it's its
career it's the murder probably wants no
post Attis murder
that's what I do I want to I'm trying to
I'm listening to everything you're
saying yeah and I'm trying to grasp on
to your point of view so I could take a
ride okay so that's what I'm doing right
now my hardest thing it's on a horse I
was just like it isn't you are moving
look what about your what about what
about personal responsibility here like
yeah you just have the kept cut so you
kept it coming back to his apartment
having sex with him because you're
afraid for your career huh
we don't know we don't know exactly
that's from her paid seven-figure sum
MVC - yeah - leave so that's what she's
eating
I'm not that's what I'm saying that's
what she sang what I'm saying though is
is that we don't know we weren't there
we don't know exactly the detail you
know what they're both saying happened
okay right yeah and then Ronan Ferran
writes that Farrell writes this book and
it's like hold on yeah well if that's
the case if you can have a relationship
with somebody and you can come back and
say this one time I was raped
well I don't know I'm with you be Matt
Lauer's a freak though huh booty from no
foot just booty for us you know he
didn't have a lock apparently under his
desk that was a lie Wow he didn't have a
button yeah because it's not the movie
this hour why I'm a Saturday huge store
I remember that I tell you why I'm
scared is because um I was flying to the
Austin comedy club cap city comedy club
one week and I wasn't going to the
airport my agent called me and says
you're out of the club there's a couple
years ago and I go what happened I'm
flying there now last year apparently
you cornered a man who was wearing a it
was a limo driver you pulled your dick
out
and you said suck my dick right now or
something like that and the guy felt
like threatened and there was some sort
of physical fix Jay
and I'm like what you like like I never
you mean like you just did to me and
then you also hit me with this shoe
that's crazy talk Bobby I can't believe
you guys nothing does that really happen
to you though there's nothing looking
because you're joking obviously no like
I was [ __ ] around
yeah but with the somebody that I don't
remember yeah and now I can never play
that club again how crazy is that
and I don't know why made good money
there I can't go there it's a great club
I love everyone there but I want to play
it again there's a lot of clubs like
that where you know what you're gonna
take a chance what businesses don't
think they don't cancel it but then
that's what but that's what I'm saying
is an accusation now carries the weight
of complete destruction that's what I'm
saying so that's why you're doing this
job I get scared because I know what the
climate slight so yeah we you and I Oh
corner somebody employer take out say
sorry I didn't do that and you learned
your lesson yeah but I didn't do that
right - right it's like you saw what I
did on camera right yeah but that was
clearly for chuckles yes playing softly
not fighting wrong you're not he's I
have never molested no I've never
fondled unless some girls or guys that
fondle me yeah you did louis c.k when we
get in yeah it's louis c.k louisiana
it's okay yeah okay anyway um what's the
next article well but others interesting
I was like oh this is a complicated
situation what what is her name was it
his crews [ __ ] any thoughts like okay
let me search loves a nice book Brooke
Nevins
Neville's was she looked like I saw her
hot no I mean ask you a question Brian
not my type but okay that's suggest I
don't know man it didn't end well
apparently yeah right thank you
you know that he took so long to answer
that I even forgot the question I wanted
to ask he's so [ __ ] angry that you
wouldn't answer it that's what happened
good thing nothing what do you got any
more great events any more rape stories
yeah let me go to the bathroom I'll go
for that yeah there's about a PR site B
yeah holidays are coming up man yeah I
look at your teeth dude and I'm gonna be
honest with you your teeth aren't very
Christmas now what is what I mean by
that they are not very jolly but they
they are so shark-like they're insulting
to me really well dude you're just
you're literally it's like I'm so sleep
on bait here I'm looking at a mini
version of a mountain range now what I
need you to do is just canned it up I'm
being candid and I want you to get
canned you trying to fix my teeth I'm
trying to fix your teeth and you can
wear you can basically wear braces and
they're see-through it's basically like
that there are liners they're more
comfortable they're removable I know
it'd be invisible in this rate them
faster than their traditional wire
braces they they straighten them faster
than your traditional wire braces rock
and water even takes about six months an
average and you have straight teeth well
experienced orthodontist who's licensed
in your state creates a custom treatment
plan they show you a 3d preview so you
can see how your teeth will look after
you're done it comes right to your door
yeah we to me no hassle yes and they
cost sixty five percent less than braces
well I've been through this and it came
along before I had a chance
Wow I know did they they make him for
the bottom or just top they I might need
them for all right top or good I went I
went with a leading company the the top
my fine he still got proud a bottom I
let cheap might not really have to go
back to candidate I might have to go
back to Canada do something listen you
can be like Brian and do something about
it
have photo ready smile by the holidays
but they also donate $25 to smile train
that brings safe 100% free cleft
and palate treatment to children around
the globe go toot and ed co.com /
fighter use code fighter to get $75 off
that's Candide code coms last fighter
code fighter for $70 off four straight
team five dollars off four straight
teeth dude yeah 75 this is nuts
candid co dot c CA ND ID candid co.com /
spider code fighter for $75 off get your
teeth straight man come on I'm about to
do it cuz I need I need it dude when I'm
at home I get my cozies I call my
clothes yeah yeah my son goes Papa
cozies here's the product and sweats bro
I got holes in mind yeah you get these
bad raggedy old sweater dude lounge
around yeah but here's the thing why not
have pants are super comfy but they also
look Austin I won't wear my sweats out
of the house it's embarrassing
we got dead in those things like why
don't you get an all-day everyday pant
from public rec okay it's your new go-to
for style comfort and versatility
alright I got a pair I can wear them in
the gym where I'm on a plane I can wear
them out and so look there in tailor
fitted yet what ster yes they listen
they have their the first sweats that
have waste and inseam sizing so whether
you're short tall or somewhere in
between they fit perfect you have you
got your dad sweats you can go the house
you wear them on the airplane - listen
don't go outside the house and your old
baggy sweats and look like trash they
got to set some slipper pockets have
some sunshine have some frickin styles
like sweats with a formal look it's
ridiculous yeah it's like your business
but you also can play hoops that's right
it's a little ball day every day for a
reason go to public wrecked cars last
rider today get tempers off your first
pair of the sweet all day every day
there is good quality as you can't for
real yes always free shipping and free
returns do not sleep on this public
wreck beach wreck re si.com slash
fighter for 10% off do I have a friend
the other day goes man I want start Kido
but I don't how do I know him ketosis
how do I know exactly when I go to
I don't know what to eat it's too much
going on he does I think it's when you
know your bodies we're running on fatty
acids nine tones it's Britain right fat
burning fat you're not burning glucose
yeah sugar yeah you're not run off
coffee sugar protein and fat and five
yeah and I told it dude you need keto
that's KEYT oh the makers of the keto
breath sensor and keto premium of the
most accurate consistent the first-ever
user-friendly Brut Bluetooth
breathalyzers for your phone it's an app
on your phone man so also when you go to
a restaurant
it has selections on there to tell you
what you can eat what not to eat
makes keto easier than over car and you
know if you're in ketosis mmm you
definitely know if you're in ketosis all
right and sensors and supreme
subscriptions are available at get keto
dot-com slash fighter that's the keto
app is available for both Android and
your iPhone all you do is search the App
Store go to Quito that's TKE
whitey oh alright and then you enter
promo code fighter you get 20% off your
first purchase yeah so tell me what does
he get the killer this box a Monthly
prescription box of heart-healthy food
and snacks curated by Kito's nutrition
team that's an $80 plus retail value
available while supplies last so we you
know what enter promo code fighter go to
keep get Quito get ki TOCOM slash
fighter get 20% off your first purchase
get back into the scene so let's do
these guys and the bad news
talking about heavy [ __ ] we got heavy
and we got really heavy it's not top
secret comedies about death about death
and secret comedy secrets alright what
do you guys got here we go
so Marc Maron went on to his podcast and
he says that he doesn't agree with Todd
Phillips's statement saying that PC
culture is ruining comedy he has a quote
basically saying if you're too
intimidated to try to do comedy that is
deeper provocative or even a little
controversial without hurting people
then you're not good at what you do or
maybe you're just insensitive what do
you guys think about that
because he's responding the Todd
Phillips when I got out of common ok
because that's because Todd was getting
a lot of a lot of a lot of these critics
were talking about how what King Phoenix
was probably the kind of guy that would
inspire violence no no no no you're off
on that
so Todd Phillips same he'd left comedy
to do the Joker because the only promise
to PC Todd's always been the guy who
pushed the envelope
I mean Todd's always been the guy who
did [ __ ] that we were like what if from
his documentaries to his movies The
Hangover is outrageous you see a dick
and at the end I mean the lot Davis
you're like what I've been here's
something to consider those buddy moot
the hangovers that that's gone yeah the
commies aren't doing he's just involved
so it was just a bit it's a business
move - yeah like he's so talented he can
do the Joker but name the last comedy
movie that's crushed it like they don't
they just don't it's over everyone has
to run like though that rat pack of
comedy it went from you know will fare
on that group to Seth Rogen that that's
it's over yeah yeah you know group will
they well emerge but then I feel like
the new group is close to closer - in
our neck of the woods not a percent yeah
but I do think that there is I do think
that that comedy that PC culture isn't
good for art I don't think it's killing
it though I think I think you're
responding that gives you something to
fight against but I also think you're
responding to the
loud the 2% under the the loudest say
you know Marvel can give a [ __ ] Dave
Dave Chappelle could give a [ __ ] they
are great because they are bucking
against that trend they're like this is
[ __ ] what they're just making
commonlook through the tube or the all
the biggest comics in the world just
they sell out everywhere arena attack
they're worried around that they're
worried that this in cells are gonna use
the Joker as some sort of biblical you
know foundation to go on a violent rage
we've always had in cells in our society
okay
there's always a group of people guys
out there that can't get [ __ ] no matter
how hard they try yes and I want to say
this is this might be controversial but
I feel like I am an in cell that I broke
out free Wow did you made it I'm gonna
tell you this I got laid though no no
not always
yeah what happened was when I was in
high school I realized during Sadie
Hawkins mm-hmm that's a Winter Formal
no that's when the girl asked the guys
out when the girl asked it's the best I
never went
you were never asked stop that was the
best I enjoyed it
never went and of course you would
enjoyed it you know why you Bubba got
asked Lily physically people open up you
son of a [ __ ] you're a son of a [ __ ] oh
are you mr. varsity blues mr. giant [ __ ]
I went to the day of muscles and
shoulders away anyway some of us go on
Bobby didn't get asked some of us got
funny no don't please don't finish my
[ __ ] walk I wrote my cousin Andy my
fat cousin Andy and I used to take
microlight a brown Corolla like I'm
station wagon oh yeah we put it on the
edge of a cliff and we'd sit on the hood
overlooking cities Hawkins
where the school was Polly high school
yeah on a cliff and I used to talk to
Andy about
they're killing ourselves we're killing
everybody in there right you know just
just as a talk yeah yeah you're right
and then you graduate from high school
and you realize oh I'm never gonna get
[ __ ] mm-hmm yeah because I now not only
am I have I have the in cell packaging
right now I have no I don't have the
sparse smarts so I can't develop an app
to make money we get good grades in high
school college did you pee playing video
games yeah right now I'm in trouble
yes right so at 23 I walked by The
Comedy Store in La Jolla because I was
walking to work because that there was a
coffee shop that you're always funny
that word you watch cracking your friend
I don't know okay no I was scared like I
will probably on some databases yeah I
mean yeah yeah my name was on some lists
okay and as I walk by and I did a Help
Wanted sign and I thought to myself I
have to either try or become nothing
mmm and I tried I knocked on the door I
got a job I did the Open Mic I became a
regular now it moved up and now look
right so I'm an in cell that like you
know got out of his predicament yeah but
we've always had in cells you know so
that that's a very there's not a joker
there looking for any so that's a legit
I hope people hear that because that's
like that's form of desperation where
you go I have one shot to get out of
this or I'm gonna be nothing
yeah but in cells have to realize it's
in their mind mmm you feeling in cell
and you're like in a you know you know
one-bedroom apartment somewhere Jack and
Eve jerking off you know even the valley
or whatever and you're thinking I [ __ ]
like this and I just know right that
we've all been there yes you know
and some women baby something hurt every
once a while
dolma bone got wrong that's it bad no do
you have to cut that out
I don't never bad yeah is that a bad
point of view no I'm not all in cells a
bone so they they don't say it's not
with the woman's responsibility
so you know what don't do anything women
and [ __ ] you in cells Jesus dude you
just turn I don't know culture guy no I
know sometimes do you guys have to cut
me up I don't know what I'm doing story
though no no I was talking you guys were
like no but I like that story doesn't
say nothing you're like keep going you
don't know what you're talking about
going but I have pretty shirt down but I
appreciate that story and I won't sorry
is what half sure it's not to say that
well it's not the seventies but you
believe so then when I was I did the
comedy store every single boy I know and
then one day Jennifer field came up to
me this white woman mm-hm
and she was 23 and she's like hey I live
in Oceanside another with my mom you
know was a sight
you should come over tomorrow my I went
over there but something you perform and
I did 69 with her in her mom's Claudia
Lee yeah that's what so oh good I never
had no Lee was she white [ __ ] she's
young and hot that's when I remember
Jesus Christ yes no I remember being in
the clock put your pimp no no I'm doing
a scene now all right
yeah everything's in the closet right oh
god I remember doing the class
neither clap with the class in the
closet you know and I'm doing it you
know whatever was you ask I - Brian what
I'm doing this don't go yeah yeah yeah
no yeah yeah right they ain't going and
I remember looking up at the heavens
right going the brown heaven yep yeah I
think look the Lord Jesus
vagina taste like Heineken yeah yeah
then did you that's what happened to us
dinner in hot blood that's from that's
from a book called the brief and one his
life of Oscar Wow first time he goes out
on a girl's ski he goes she tasted like
Heineken Deena by Junot Diaz is when we
get to I went there to him busting them
is that the game anyone like and she was
how did that did she just start how did
that happen
like 69 is a bold first move it's
aggressive he didn't start I didn't go
from walking into the front door and 69
there's a built there's like a thing
yeah that's good right so cuz I didn't
she could I thought maybe she was like
can you clean the pool yeah because I
had never had a girl
come up to me and go I want to heal with
you in a sexual way so when they said
when they said let's hang out I always
thought was a job like I'll have to move
something or you know I mean it's none
of us so when I when I went to her house
we had dinner and they came back around
by the closet though wasn't their bed
they're not I think because she had
animals like a lot yeah get in the hot
get in the closet
but let me say something I [ __ ] her
maybe 20 times that summer yeah yeah
yeah I mean I literally would cry yeah
it's the greatest liar no you were 23
also being a fat asian guy yeah Korean
dude doing this in the late mid-1995 you
know all these Ali Wong's and all these
other like Jimmy listings and all you
should be thanking you they should be
blowing me but um and walking the doors
trimmed I nod to judo Mizzou the Jackie
Robinson of Asia
did I not one of the greats right
Robinson one of the greats I'm one of
the greats am I not yeah you got a dude
you gotta put your shirt down man shell
I wonder what that girl's doing now
you're thinking about that no I don't
wanna I don't want to what'd she look
like
I don't know what did she look like back
then she was blond beautiful eyes maybe
be nice fat being to these though big
titties yeah very big but beautiful face
Princess Diana died though that's how I
know that's how I opened the
conversation Diana died yeah yeah Diana
died so that will how far a little what
year was that when Diana died 1994 I'd
say three I'm gonna say 94 it would have
to be after 95 because that's when I
started doing stand-up so 95 is when I
started and I know that she had died and
these seven so yeah so that's why that
happened so when 97 I was working the
door at the La Jolla Comedy Store that
date which is probably a Saturday I
don't know but I did I opened for Jo koy
and he had some old school the guy was
Asian said he opened he worked with you
at the time there was a door guy
bigger dude okay he's Asian does he
location yes kind of could be Mexican he
said he was Asian anyway
so just rewind what he just said there
all right sometimes confusing you know I
said is the Asian you go kind of but
could be Mexican
no I'm saying he's for sure Asian but if
you didn't know for sure he my bike is
that a big Mexican so if I was blind I
could go maybe he's a Mexican that's
right yeah you could yeah hey what are
you saying salience Reyes it's ray why
would you each other engine running out
Laila no what do you mean he's low
energy no cuz he starts thinking about
his own career know his own nepotism
make it about him you think don't use
him have a team or tomorrow what he's
doing he would tomorrow
Bobby's got this he's got a good funny
point of view into tomorrow and then I
got a call a see ya the Wardrobe thing
and then my hair there do you know what
nepotism means they say nepotism yeah
who knows what a nepotism I know what
never doesn't mean alright now that's
what I wanted to say narcissism you know
I know what now but nepotism is what
will says Will Smith is doing with his
son yes that's what it is yes it's where
you promote those you're related to my
position Authority where they don't man
I mean we got a couple more current
events let's do a couple you got bit
Laos out of this thing yeah we did yeah
I mean my knee hurt last my knee hurts I
feel you're kind of mean to me man
robbed a bank
I'm sorry so this man last Friday went
and robbed a local bank in Texas in
order to pay for a wedding ring and pay
off his wedding that was going to be the
following day thoughtful girl later that
afternoon his photo and video went viral
and his fiancee actually saw and
convinced him to turn himself in oh gosh
I it's love who thinks they're gonna get
away with robbing a bank
that guy was acting
no mask nothing that that's incredible
this guy this guy with no mask goes in
there with a hat and and he's trying to
get out of his marriage
no nose name he loves the [ __ ] out his
name is Esprit his name is Heath bumpass
mm-hmm
I mean dude you know real stupid you
have to be to think you could rob a bank
with no math and get away I'm gonna put
this how even with a mask even I'm
asking me tough but at least your hops
can figure it out wow you breathing hard
over there dudes are you Bobby Bobby
just passes on next oh boy so a photo of
those ears Ellen DeGeneres and George W
Bush went viral a couple days ago that's
all these were both a football game a
Cowboys game against the Packers and a
lot of people were giving Ellen some
hate over sitting and seemingly having a
good time with George W Bush
so she addressed on her show yeah be
really serious yeah be a real loser to
even give a [ __ ] yeah also she's a lot
of talk to the president Isis
[Music]
that's the show older demos I want to
leave to Bobby hold on Bobby
we love you man [ __ ]
Bobby Lee on the head Bobby on the 500th
episode he just took off just took off
this took all the energy on my body I
just don't care like I don't know why
you even gives a [ __ ] yeah but elements
annexed to the presidents like alright
yeah ok you know I don't get like who
would throw hey that Eleanor Georgia
pleasure boy who gives a but I agree how
does it end though what did she say she
basically says that you need to be kind
to everybody
alright so bad dude you got a little
bored and we now we have you been yeah
alright next going trying to producer
over the show was on you know that right
she produced a sitcom I was on she
actually there just twice there you go
for two years anyway I guess here what's
his name so you can see him either do
you guys make made with funny jokes
about that she I think you Ellen
DeGeneres in her time was one of the
best comics to ever do he was one of my
fish on HBO back in the day so good she
her HBO specials a half-hour were like
so inspirational to me months because
her jokes were clinical joke that the
joke writing you know a lot of um I
don't want to be I'm not I don't want to
confront that I'm trying to get racial
but a lot of back in the day black
comics you would sell things based on
attitude which I love as well right
but Ellen's joke writing was so cute and
quirky and clever my job my buddy
directed about 200 episodes of her show
and said she was so [ __ ] [ __ ]
phenomenal undeniable huh she just an
improv scene yes she is great and then
she go okay bro let me try this and she
just come up with is just a moderate
phenomena then she took how many years
off and then came back and didn't stop
doing standeth alright she stopped doing
it and then came back Oh is she doing it
acknowledge is it
oh wow I think Neil helped her without
Neal Brennan wrote oh yeah yeah yeah
what do you know where we go we don't
know you're with
last Monday just really rude yesterday
Instagram actually disabled the
following tab so now you can like and
comment on other people's posts without
your friends knowing oh oh so you can't
see what you like yeah so is that good
or bad I think that's I mean when you're
having when you're having a relationship
yeah because a lot of people catch it's
called I guess micro cheating where you
like someone's photos a little too often
micro cheese or you're leaving comments
on your ex's photos and that's where all
my fights with my girlfriend and kalila
is I was like so um you like so-and-so's
girlfriend and I go what yeah you like
like six of her photos I see all the and
you're like oh yeah this is hot
I thought there didn't get rid of being
able to see followers - I think they're
still in the works of trying to figure
out whether they want to do that or not
how many followers yeah Bobby on its own
oh here we go that you're doing with the
Lea dodge I'm not you're gonna go oh you
only have that the note I have I'm
actually what he's new hello - right in
my face so he's doing what do you have
Bry like 7 million notice there's this
girl who was so good looking at and
scram when you search and I was like
Jesus Christ she was so good-looking I
was like who is she ten point four
million followers and 24 million
followers that's a crazy she just threw
do you got it you found I found her so
she came up with my feet he's hot so
everyone falls oh wow I wonder about the
people are not following her though I
only have four and 55,000 that's kind of
a lot puppy what do you have Brendan I
don't know like a million I don't know
what you're talking about
really I've been here a while really
good to have me yeah
Bobby thank you for having a really
there Bobby what's next bi enjoy when
are you on the road again
no I'll gonna tell you all the little
things I got going on no please do I'll
tell you I'm doing a little Netflix
Netflix some animation show what's it
called big now it's going out the idea
of table Friday me Brett Gelman a bunch
of people and then I'm but um stop
talking like this make me angry I don't
know what
I don't I believe start talking
hey be respectful of my studio right now
all right you want money for that I'll
pay for it yeah I do not use it
hey yeah [ __ ] your shirt down right now
get your dick out no limo driver now
pull that [ __ ] put get your hand that
smell something interesting right no
nope good binder huh
no but let's let's be real you know what
here's what I'll do
I'm gonna stand up and say good good
good good bye closing
monologue please and then I'm just gonna
leave do I'm gonna having to eat and do
a closing now I know I want to have to
do with the drops knife it's a standoff
Rob Schneider it's 7:00
he wants to send off this be the final
send-off for Bobby Lee 500 under it's
500 please be respectful 500 be
respectful Bobby don't make hello thank
you take your time take your time three
shades are red three shades are a rather
rather to get red leather yellow leather
red leather yellow leather yeah that's
how you do I just like this that much
you know over the years I haven't I
haven't had a I said I've had good
things but bad things happened in my
life
sure what hey get on with it you [ __ ]
mollusk before I beat you I feel like
[ __ ] being Mina's last couple of
months have been really tough in my life
this year has been really tough I've had
some great things and really devastating
things happen you know I was on a show
got canceled I was devastated and then I
got to Clinton a couple of other things
and then was good and then my dad died
it was really devastating but at the end
of the day the reason why I'm here is
because I like to go and say hi to
people that I love and and and comedy
places where I feel comfortable and this
is one of them and I really am just
blessed that you guys are my friend
and blessed that I feel like my career
has just started I feel I'm meeting so
many because of Tiger valium because I'm
a part of this world I'm meeting a lot
of love out there in a lot of business
we have people and it feels great and I
really appreciate your love your love
you man and when I funniest people don't
bring up my special again because I'm
doing all right
yeah you are
I love it you love the movies the one
with the UM when Martin Sheen is in the
water
yeah oops now he comes out with his face
it and then the knife oh that's
Apocalypse Now yeah it's old movie man
yeah but you're talking about Americans
in Vietnam now yeah there's a little bit
more than that oh wait dixie got stuck
in your life ah [ __ ] yeah I was in
college man be less sloppy
oh that's a good luck look at that pubic
bump you got out you got a real gun
fluence ours Oh Oh Holly died you gave
me you a nice arse with your butt crack
was it was that good today or bad I feel
like it was a chaos the worst podcast of
the night I'm so sorry without a little
off I'm so sorry yeah you're fun are you
sure you know here's a reason why it's
also scary to do your podcast why in the
reason why I haven't been on in a while
because you've been asking I know how he
does it till he does it in a sly way and
it's always like in one hour can you
feel it it's like what the [ __ ] yeah
now a lot of yeah you don't give me a
lot of leeway a good planner yeah but
what I wanted to say was is that um I
young love you bye oh man Bobby leave